if I did some brain surgery on your and
I hold your brain in my hand nothing in
your body of a function
no genome no genetic activation I can be
raised in the same household experience
the same challenge the same divorce I
can still view the world in a different
way than you you've done it from this
one child could have a more negative
perception of the world in the other but
it's not Geneva TV why are you talking
about you were thinking feeling and
choosing switches with jeans on I get
that but what does that have to do my
question can we predict that there is a
certain type of brain that will do a
certain tapas no your corn that's
completely and utterly unscientific and
lacking in evidence you see a lot that's
coming up all the medication that we
being asked to take they drugs they
might have medicine do you have the
ability to prescribe me any medication
those drugs have no positive effects
except nominee fix so you don't fear AI
threat at all the greatest contribution
for in technology has made is that a
brain constantly changes
[Music]
did you ever think you would make good I
feel I'm suppose I could take sweet
victory I know this slice meant for me
here yeah why would you bet on July 4 we
got red tape value came in given values
contagious this world of entrepreneurs
we can't no value to haters honey run
homie look what I become I'm the one
[Music]
so my guest today is dr. Caroline leaf
who happens to be a cognitive
neuroscientist and also communication
pathologist and her strategies have been
used by millions of people worldwide
mind management techniques I want to say
correctly mind management techniques by
over a million people and some of you
may be watching this thinking this
videos for you but really this is for me
to figure out all my mental issues I
have for the next hour hour and a half
so I welcome you and doctor thanks for
coming out for me when I think about
cognitive neuroscientists or somebody's
listening saying communication
pathologists what does that really mean
to an average person like myself okay so
in a simple language I study the mind
brain connection which I've done for 30
years do clinical research so I look at
how what is the mind how does that work
what is the brain how does that work
what's the relationship and what's the
impact on how we function in terms of
our behaviors or emotions how we
function on dates in day-to-day life
education work whatever so it's looking
at all of that so as a clinical when I
practice clinically which I did for 25
years I would look a patient that would
come to me with whatever brain tumor or
physical told me emotional torment
learning issues Alzheimer's whatever I
would look at the external behavior
social emotional cognitive what they're
doing and then track back to what's
going on in the thought life so in other
words what's happening in the mind and
then also look at the impact on the
brain and the body and then try to
address all the levels that's pretty
much very interested did you did you
also deal with bipolar ADHD depression
anxiety panic attacks kids of all of
those that I have a very different
narrative for that because I don't what
you get into okay I can't wait to get
into some it's a really good I have some
questions for you on that because you
experience a lot of that in the business
world is filled with a lot of those
personalities there's a link also to
success with it you know what I want
Kherson I think good way to go so look
you have the mind you have the brain
what's the difference between your mind
at the bright brilliant question so your
mind is the most simple definition the
unique way
that you think and feel and choose so
those two go together as you think you
always feel but we're thinking we're
thinking beings you never stop thinking
24/7 so but as soon as you think you
feel so you're always feeling 24/7 and
as you think and feel it automatically
leads to choices so you think you're
choose think feel choose think think
feel choose your doing this on two
levels the one level is the conscious
level that that you're in when you're
awake and that level happens around
every 10 seconds we are consciously and
deliberately aware of thinking feeling
and choosing and the way we do that has
massive impact on mental health which I
know we're going to unpack the other
level is the non conscious level so not
subconscious but non conscious that
operates 24/7 and at that level we
operate a team to the 17 which is about
400 billion plus actions per so that's
crazy
so we functioning on these incredible
levels of speed that that and that's all
mind this mind is this all this thinking
feeling choosing on these two different
levels
this power energy whatever you want to
call it moves through your physical
brain so your brain is a responder to
your mind so there's an interaction they
do two things but they interact they
can't your chronic one without the other
so your mind moves through our brain and
then our brain responds on a chemical
level quantum level electromagnetic
level and genetic level so we literally
put stuff in our brain and then I'll
brain responds and builds that stuff
into the cells of the brain and that
instantly influences all the cells of
the body so this brain and body
collectively the two togethers of the
brain and the body are made of about 75
to 100 trillion cells and that brain and
body it's a big number
and that's only 1% of who you are as a
human so 99% of who you are as a human
is this mind thing thus unique eunice
this type you thus Patrick's is Caroline
that's what separates us from everybody
yes okay let's be defining
connect/disconnect
because we've all got the brain right
but the way we you the way you use your
brain is going to be different
we work with the same basic
neurophysiology in our brain structures
etc the way I use my brain it's pretty
much my signature my thumbprint to the
world that's mine that's what it exactly
you'll see that in the brain the brain
is literally like a thumbprint
so there so in essence I can be raised
in the same household experience the
same challenge the same divorce same
parents I'm a twin everything could be
identical the same experiences that can
be looking like somebody else my
attractiveness is the same level as
somebody else my level of popularity in
school is the same as somebody else I
date the same kind of a girl or guys
somebody else playing culture same same
same same religious same church I go to
I'm an atheist a Christian I'm a
psychologist my 20 years old I can still
view the world in a different way than
you you've done it from birth you've
done it with totally totally different
this is why we see studies of identical
twins we you'll have one next in old age
same thing just as you described and one
gets Alzheimer's and one is still firing
up and still going along you know how
you perceive things makes your body work
for you against you and this is the
clinical research that I do me showing
this right down to the level of your DNA
and you see you don't even have to do to
do the research to know that instinct
it's your gut instinct do not the same
to someone else yeah that's crazy to me
because what that makes me think about
doc and by the way if you don't mind me
calling your doctor what that makes me
think about doc is you know in America I
was reading a study the other day I was
talking to Jordan Peterson I don't even
then we had an ask him questions let me
ask you this are we born Democrats and
Republicans like are we born because I
remember I'm talking to someone's a
girlfriend at that time I said let me
ask you a question and politically we
were talking about economics and she
completely disagrees with capitalism
I said how good were you in math in high
school should I can't stand man I said
curious to know how much math plays a
role so for me I want to know are we
born a certain way you know today we
were handling an issue in the company
one person they can't help themselves
stop about an issue in somebody else
about the same issues excited about it
then somebody call mrs. Pat what can I
do to better this I said it for seven
years this person has been like this
you and I can't change it the person's
got to want to change it for that to be
taking place so that person that's one
with a different perception of the world
can I be raised with a percent
perception of the world where I'm always
looking at the glass half-empty or can
that still be fixed for somebody that
can be fixed so here's some yes yes
here's the good news the good news is
that be positive no no they give you the
real I'm gonna give you no I don't do
that I don't I don't even believe in
that so that's not where I'm at but what
I do know is from this neuroscientific
research plus from quantum physics plus
from experience plus from mind research
all of it we see that there isn't a
single structure for example in the
brain a single circuit a single cell in
the entire human body and brain that is
designed for seeing the glass half empty
we're designed to see the glass half
full we literally at a quantum level or
body you see us physically now we're
looking at each other but at your most
fundamental level
you literally waves of energy and those
rays of energy the quantum physicists
the mathematicians for example Sir Roger
Penrose who's the top mathematician of
the century in my opinion and many
people's opinions they've done the
calculations literally showing that we
are made of love and we are immersed in
gravitational fields that have the
qualities of love so now let me take
that there is as a default mode humanity
is designed to operate in love and I'm
not turning all fluffy here and over
whatever I'm being a realist I'm a very
real scientist and I believe science is
very spiritual so it's a very strong
connect you can't separate the two so we
see scientifically a beautiful thing
happening through mathematics through
quantum physics we see a description of
humanity as being this love concept now
we know that if you go across every
culture dealed every human if you talk
to every human on this planet that ever
was and ever will be there's one common
thing that we all agree on and that is
we love love our families or we when
operating level we need love to function
it's the number one addiction people
cannot live without love people die from
a lack of love you literally can shut
your body down and die from love in this
day and age or we have we have people
dying at the same rate from the lack of
love in our solution as
due from cardiovascular disease which is
pretty much a number-one killer how do
they do there's a lot of research
statistics really showing yes you can
you can because you see it shutting down
that's the research that I mean so you
can see lack of love is a big word you
can bring it down to how people are
managing stress on a day to day basis or
chronic inflammation in the body or
chronic stress ongoing so if you're
constantly isolated you don't get the
correct feedback in your but because you
this there's a certain feedback that
you're getting from interacting with
others like this we are building on each
other we are growing each other we are
sending an understand spoke about the
photons that we our son called my eye
over there about the photons that we
generate from our body I'm generating
photons to you I'm generating
photons that are operating in love in
terms of it's really having a
conversation we're agreeing to agree or
disagree
there isn't an enmity between us so it's
growing us and humans are designed for
that what are the stories that grab us
the most the stories that are of
humanity so that's not basic and we see
that so we sit near a scientifically we
see at quantum physics wise we see we
design for that so why does someone see
the glass half-empty and why do I say we
can change it I don't believe in the
happiness industry where you can go and
get something and put it in an awesome
are you happy I don't believe in
positive affirmations they're band-aids
you've got an issue you slap a positive
affirmation on it's not gonna fix
anything what we have to look at is why
am I saying
the glass is half-empty so that is my
perception why there's a reason so soon
as we move out of that massive
definition of what love is because it
basically is being a decent human and
it's got multitude of infinite ways of
viewing that as soon as we move out of
that these these there's a disconnect
between humans between how we
functioning between how we fit in the
world between our impact in the world
etc and as soon as we do that that these
are really that's going to have a
consequence because your mind is moving
through your brain your brain builds
that perception physically into your
brain so you're thinking feeling
choosing moment by moment of everyday
and if he ever take a scenario where I'm
constantly seeing a negative thing you
talked about your guy who can't see me
on this whatever the situation so if I
have now more than four more than 63
days
simply thought in a certain way I have
built a very strong tree in my brain
that's I've got trees eeeh
a tree is a thought or thoughts or real
things they look like trees they occupy
mental real estate they made of proteins
they are tortured right now you are
growing at the speed of 400 billion
actions you're converting my words and
so the listeners into trees in their
brain hopefully they're building our
cell see trees about what we're saying
but not you for I inhabit if you've done
something for years and you've thought
in a way for years because of an
experience because of environment so
this net nurture you born was as I
mentioned this wired full of design we
in nurture environment and all the other
stuff you described now there's the i
factor the two turns going through life
same thing but how they seen it so each
experience is not adding more and more
layers to my initial core so here I am
born but here I am perceiving I may
perceive the two twins one perceives a
relationship in this way one perceives a
situation in this way two different
networks building the brain and as you
keep thinking in that certain way so you
strengthen whatever you think about the
most grows into a toxic search that's
the path I fully see that there's a
question that so can I be born more
negative than you you know you can't be
born more negative and what you can have
which is total science it's epigenetics
your DNA will come through from your
parents so it goes through the sperm
only over but that DNA is not you've got
two types of DNA that comes through so
you're born with your genetic blueprints
and that genetic blueprint is this wired
for love perfection on top of that we
have so you've got a JIT you've got a
gene code that is basically perfect okay
on top of that you believe oh yes I do
because I can show you scientifically so
let me let me explain how this works so
you've got a basic core then on top of
that you've got the DNA from let's come
through generations and that's the
imperfect stuff so humans or make
choices when you make choices it becomes
part of our DNA that DNA is there
constantly it's what you putting it out
in the world and what you say it's
passing through the sperm in the over so
when you were born you were born with
you
plus things from the parents generations
back whatever so you've got a bunch of
imperfection on top of perfection but
I'm born with imperfection as well yes
it's boys so it's yes oh okay so you
wanna move sir okay sorry I may be sit
at wrong you boys weren't perfect okay
be born we're not born blanks laughing
up on perfect let me rephrase that we
are born with a core that's perfect with
a bunch of other stuff on top and what
we see we can even track disease back
diseases lifestyle related lifestyle is
choices thinking how we respond to the
world as we mutate genes so we get the
propensity to disease that's but but
only 5% is going to come from that gene
propensity so you've got the stuff
inside of you on top of your original
core design and that is now activated to
nurturing so let's say now your parents
were depressed and you're you've got a
history of of people in very depressed
in your family all very negative just in
row negative oppressed like people that
just uh you know we see the glass half
empty so now you born with that those
mutated genes on top of your genes but
here's the great news they're born that
you're born with in asleep they dormant
it's called dormancy so the genes are
dormant which means that you're no your
genes are active other which couldn't
live your genes have to be active but
you've got what's dormant is what's
passed through the generations so it's
the stuff that came through the sperm in
the over it's the imperfect genes on top
of the genes so it's mixed in amongst
your genome is your genome which is
active otherwise you couldn't be a lot
and then you've got into woven on top of
that you have your in your impure stuff
that's come through the generations
coming through dormant which means it's
sealed it's closed it's not active how
do you wake it up with your perception
your response your mind how you think
feel and choose so now our child's
growing up in a oh this child here this
negativity all this child sees is all
going fine team etc that is now
environmental influence coming in the
child still learning so the child can
maybe make such a good decisions so the
child's immersed in negativity so now in
environments negative that then wakes up
to the dormant genes and that could
start manifesting and then you start
seeing patterns of behavior in the child
becoming negative but now we have two
twins in the family and both are exposed
to this negativity one is definitely
more negative
the other I'm just giving you a snore
okay so good and but that's coming from
perception it's not coming from they've
had they've got the same baby 2000
negative it's coming from perception
which is mind which is how you think
feelings you know exactly it's the in
could have a more negative perception of
the world than the other but it's not
genetically pre-wired it is modulated
it's activated through thinking feeling
choosing so the the genes are not self
emergent let me explain it like this if
I pull your brain actual head if I did
some brain surgery on you right now
which I won't and I'll hold your brain
in my hand it's not going to do anything
I can look at it all day long you did
nothing in your body will function no
Gino no genetic activation nothing will
have no genes or switch on but the fact
that you are alive and I haven't done
that the only reason your brain and
genes are doing anything is because of
your thinking feeling and choosing it's
firing them up it is the switch on your
thinking feeling and choosing switches
your genes on my question so okay my
question being the fact that I'm trying
to perception I'm born with I asked a
question earlier which how much of it is
my DNA my environment might this and
let's just say everything is the same
and you and I born same girlfriend same
boyfriend saying this and I'm Christian
should all this is why this one why so
you've got two kids in the family and
ones negative and one is so-so but I'd
like to have three kids right okay and I
see a lot of people that came from a
great family like okay that got became a
successful that guys in prison this
guy's in the military that guy
everything's bad in his life since he
was a kid this versus parents lived a
decent life how much of that is them
like you know I talk about teacher
versus the individual how much of is the
teacher the example how much of is the
individual how much of is the
environment so I'm just a teacher
environment is all one category so
that's nurture so under nurture we would
have all of those things you describe so
you born with your physical and in your
foot nurture then you've got the I
factor so the eye effect is the dominant
one it's the 99% it's this thing that
overrides so your two kids in the family
was the same thing you've got the one
who will now literally activate by
thinking negative oh I'm seeing this
negative I choose to think negative
and they start activating the negative
genes and I've got the propensity
activated and I'm continuing in that way
of thinking it's a choice that I make
because at any stage I can recognize you
can train a person very easily - stand
back observe the I'm thinking because
it's neuroscience it's how we are
designed it's quantum physics it's all
of that you can stand back and observe
your own thinking and you can show
someone can you see that you being
negative can you see that that is and
you think it's about showing people
there's always a way for someone to see
it but not even will choose to do that
but and then one of the greatest ways of
people think that is the impact on other
people so it could be so relational we
so designed for deep meaningful
community so that person who constantly
sees negative in your meeting is
irritating eventually that's going to
get to a point where you all kind of ah
you know like oh I'm just giving that
exhaust in saving that person that
person has to say themselves but it
takes a community takes community to
make them away but they can still be a
way and choose to say the same let's
just say they have a great coming like
you know how you go to church yeah yeah
you get the whole thing and they storing
it and yeah you know how like I remember
one time a buddy of mine call me this is
Pat my marriage didn't work out okay
this is how do you do it so how do i do
what how do you make a marriage work at
somebody I take one you're out of time I
have no idea if it's gonna work out next
year marriage is not an easy things a
lot of work he says okay but what's your
what's effective for you I said you know
10 years ago I asked people I said
what's the benefit which I was I was an
atheist for 25 years now I'm very much
against a whole thing Church thing at
first going up any one guy says look
here's what you got to realize there's a
benefit of being around a community of
people that are making their marriages
work because a community helps you want
to achieve um it's kinda like you know
Mackey man you know she loves you man
you guys got to figure this out I know
you kind of like Big Macs but she
doesn't like it but you got to figure
out a way to make this relationship work
and hey I just don't know if I can be
what there's a party what are you
talking about and it's like I can't deal
with me so stubborn you got to do this
doc you know you guys been together for
22 years okay we'll make it work right
so that's standard but what if he's like
nope I don't want to do anything that's
a choice they've made so choice and
that's the I sector see the choice comes
in remember I said - think he'll choose
yeah
that is your unique you own that right
so what we photo recognizes what we own
we are not thinking feeling and choosing
so that person those two kids in the
family the situation you've just
described you can take the horse to the
water it's that situation but the horses
in the water
that's so yeah and that's the mind
that's the eye factor that's the part
that we are not have not done enough
research on that I've spent 30 years
myself researching there are a few of us
doing it but we've got to focus on that
because otherwise I can use my brain as
an excuse for everything which is the
day and age we live in you can't make
the relationship work
they've got ADHD that's why they go make
what to say what that day that's why no
that's not why those are those are
effects if this is a great I've got a
great in each other you want to have a
look at this is a very powerful image
what we're gonna see here is a real
human brain this is a real-life person
linked up to very advanced brain
technology and that firing that you see
over there is thinking feeling choosing
if you would date there'd be no firing
in the brain so what we're seeing is
energy moving through the brain that is
being picked up by very complex
technology that is showing the brain
responding to an alive person who's
thinking feeling choosing so this is the
conversation or this is just steady
that's all the time oh so your brain
looks like that now but you're firing
would be different to mine different to
every single viewer so everyone has
their own unique way that the brain
actually fires up so these a uniqueness
your brain is designed to match you it
responds to you and you drive that so if
I'm constantly negative
I Drive a negative quantum energy
through the brain which will then cause
still cause an electrochemical and
electromagnetic and genetic reaction but
it's going to be distorted and that
means that I'm gonna make something
that's all distorted oh I'm gonna do a
healthy thought or and whatever you want
to call it let that and I'm going to
then change what it looks like that's
why I've got green trees and toxic trees
so if you look at this next slide this
really makes it clear this these are
neurons okay and you see them moving and
so it's kind of the same it's it's also
in the brain if you were dead they'd be
no movement and that what you see these
things growing that's what's happening
in your brain at speeds that are very
very fast you growing little branches
those branches so it's growing
in its its building constant you
building now you don't stop meant what
causes it to develop no thinking feeling
and choosy if you date a dozen so let me
ask you there's this mean to more I'm
learning and reading as a building more
more all the time you deem it all
there's no way to measure three brains
of one developing versus one not if we
can see that we can see a response your
brain you study the brain I work with
scientists up doing my own research now
we see that with Lucy's brain thickening
you see changes fascinating right there
because yeah you you actually see I've
got another slide over here will well
okay we've got another slide after we've
yet to post the state of this thing
there's another slide that shows an
inside the actual brain I don't have it
over here but you can actually see what
you're asking me let me see if it's over
here here we go okay this is fascinating
yeah that's intense to me yeah it is
intense and this is what people don't
realize but you're doing that you try
know what that means
that means when you're thinking you're
reading learning more your brain is
growing and growing muscles it's gray
not even it's growing branches it's
growing computers and those computers so
you this is inside your brain you've got
infinite space in your brain you
designed to think you're supposed to
think you're supposed to grow your brain
one of the biggest aspects of mental
health that is the most under is an
aspect of mental health that I've been
fighting for thirty years to get out
into into people's minds and and and
understanding and that I do with my
research is building your brain with
your mind if you don't build your brain
if you're not learning new stuff if
you're not really using your brain every
day it's like not cleaning your house
I'm not cleaning your teeth or not
washing your body your brain builds up
so so what it has there been researched
to study what builds the brain more is
it play is it seeing a movie that
creates your imagination is it reading
is it relationship is it olofi about is
there one that doesn't one in the other
the it's how you once again your
effector if I approach a relationship
with deep intensity and I really start
everything at it I'm growing my brain
very effectively if I take material and
I study it intensity so that I can
understand it and I can actually teach
it that's more effective than if I just
took it and just scan through it or if I
just approach the relationship
in terms of comparing across them it's
all dependent on how you are using your
perception how you're using your mind
that builds health into the brain so
constantly you'll have people that are
that are constantly like a therapist for
example who's always interacting with
people and diving into people's heads
you would find that is very that's not
an area in the brain but it's basically
that kind of skill has developed in the
brain and we can all develop
relationships of interest this has
sometimes shut down the emotion for the
therapist no because emotions are always
the-- you know what I'm talking about
okay so for instance I find myself I've
hired a therapist for the last 19 years
20 years and I'll go sit with them right
a person that had been around for 30
years it's routine a person that had
been around for five years they're
putting a little bit more effort a
person that's been out for 35 years
they're just kinda like okay so how'd it
make you feel so tell me about this
amazing they just look lazy I saw a
trend a little bit with that which
sometimes a fire was being gone but let
me go back to this I want to go a little
bit deeper with this conversation as
well so you know how a generals
historically general like generally army
leaders of the army would say you know
this country produces the best human
beings okay or the best specimen maybe
it's a better word to use you know I'm
talking to Kai Kai's from Norway he
tells me do you know Hitler believed
that the best specimen came from Norway
because whatever reasons right now why
he thinks that I have no idea why he
thinks that but you see a lot of
generals and rulers will say you know
Assyrians make the best you know people
because a blood is stem from fire and
they're you know they got this and
they're students and they're you know
original they've been out for a while
sort of all these things is there a way
is there a way for me maybe if you don't
have a right now scientifically because
this to me I mean if you have this this
is insane the rest of it is there a way
to measure a person's capacity from the
day they're born or maybe out a year old
to do a test on their brain and say this
person is wiring on how the brain is if
you feed the right information to this
person they could end up being an Elon
Musk type of guy they could end up being
the next Einstein this person could end
up being
Churchill or Alexander Hamilton because
the wiring has the ability to grow is
there a way to measure that that's no
because it's a complete new reductionism
they've tried to do it they're trying to
do it and it's the worst thing that's
ever been done because it takes away the
uniqueness of a human anyone could be
anything depending on who you are so
when it's what you reads where you go
it's all perception and why do we have
to but I'm not saying that let me
rephrase that I'm not saying everyone
can be an Elon Musk and everyone can be
an Einstein if that's not really mean
goes if you are an incredible artist
that's as brilliant as someone who is a
physicist okay so it's who you are to
the uniqueness of where you introduce so
okay so you know you can't front that's
what you're trying to say is you're a
reduction yeah what I'm not can we
predict that day is a certain type of
brain that will do a certain type of
thing and can we grow it no you can't
that's in your every action maybe let me
show let me show this to you and you
explain to me if I'm thinking the right
way okay we got three different people
okay Mary Kay Bobby
Cindy they're siblings okay Mary Bobbie
Cindy okay Mary has a higher level of
capacity in life okay she is obviously
it's very obvious from very early on
very intuitive could what people
understand you know thinks in a
different way decisions different
perspective perception of how she used
the world then Bobby's a slightly lower
than him and Lord and her and then he
got Cindy Lord and Bobby okay I'm asking
capacity if Bobby reaches this level in
life it's still lower than her if she
gets here but she's done more with her
life with his life than Mary because
Mary's potential of doing more in life
is higher so all I'm asking for is there
are people that have a higher potential
not everybody can be in Elon Musk right
not everybody can be in Einstein not
everybody can be a and that's okay
there's nothing wrong with it I'm not
making the comparison part all I'm
saying is is there a measuring mechanism
to say this person's capacity based on
the way their brain is wired is a lot
higher than another person listen to it
not at all the answer is no absolutely
no applause yes because your brain is
only one percent of how you function and
the biggest danger that's happened with
neuroscience
and the advent of Technology of the MRI
the fMRI mid nineties and the
understanding of neuroplasticity is that
people have tried to find
neurobiological correlates of
intelligence of mental health of mental
illness and it's completely and utterly
unscientific and lacking in evidence
Yale just brought out a study recently
saying that there is no normal brain
which and what that means is that every
brain has the potential to become what
that person's interest is so very good
point right there what that person's
interest is and that and then that comes
back to the effector so I can have the
most amazing desire to grow in a
direction and show signs of doing that
but there's just something about how I'm
seeing a life that could block me and
someone else who you like that you
listen to Bobby whatever who also makes
that judgment you know we've be coming
from a very materialistic view of
Studios who's allowed to say the Dec
one's got a lot potential than that one
yeah but it's still a decision someone
has said you've got more potential than
user behavior we know what it's like
it's kind of like this I will judge you
if you're 71 and you're 15 years old
there is a 40 percent chance you can end
up playing in the end yeah but that's
physical external that's a physical
you've looked at someone physically you
looked at the physical when they start
talking that person there is enough
research out there with people that they
have thought would not do very well
understand as a classic case of that we
he was seen as a slow kid he was even
told taken out of school and home school
and he because he just did not think in
the state I took a lot about that in my
book think low and succeed before to be
so careful of learning styles it's the
most inaccurate way of judging people
personality profiles IQ learning style
is not science at all for 25 years
there's been a few of us in the in the
DA in the in there in a lonely world and
are saying do not work on learning
styles because it limits people no
learning stuff people talk about being a
visual learner in order to do all that
kind of stuff so a lot of there's a lot
of education systems have been based
around for you for years on that but
that's very limiting because you cannot
say you a visual learner because you
have every single person's you don't
imagine not at all it's not even science
it's not even it's never it's actually
been
totally disprove know who has disproven
that many many scientists I can't have
many studies that occurred actually in
this book so we so basically what we
have is the learning star movement has
limited people because it's saying
you're this type of person it is has
given birth it's come out of the IQ
movement so you're either a number so
they would do a static test to see how
you responded in that moment and your
whole potential your whole life was
judged on that IQ test player much less
a role now they slip their role then we
went to the more personality learning
style content movement which put you in
a category and I said if you do X then
you that now in the same category is
this neuro reductionism which is trying
to say this is the perfect brain if you
have this kind of wiring you're going to
be able to do this it links to
artificial intelligence it you you
basically saying if you is there a
certain pattern of wiring that can that
you can activate or stimulate to to
achieve that kind of goals let me ask it
in a different way and again if if brain
are their muscles what would you call
those muscle proteins in computers
little computers would you say muscles
are little proteins yes they made you
break down to programs thank you yeah so
essentially maybe there's some
similarity there right critical energy
so for instance you know in in
bodybuilding they call it endomorph
ectomorph mesomorph
right and it's a guy like me like i have
small what do you call the joints or
what he called like here-here joints
yeah so what this does is it benefits a
bodybuilder because it makes the forearm
look bigger versus somebody who has a
bigger forearm so you're looking like
he's gonna look a box distinctive yes so
then you're looking at I don't know if
this guy's got the physique to be mr.
Olympia right you can tell very early on
if someone's got a physic to be in the
store Olympia that's that's what I'm
saying so this person may be built to be
mr. Olympia all I'm saying is this
person's got a very extremely sensitive
brain that if the proper information is
given to her and she finds something
that's passionately interested in she
has the ability to do really expand into
something very big
I'm not saying specifically putting in a
box like in Germany from ninth grade
they decide what you need to do as a
career
what you can occasionally different
right British system - right in America
it's a little bit more flexible if they
did that to me I'd be broken because
that would have gone a different
direction
I'm just asking measurement to say the
it's not even IQ think it's a pure like
looking at the way it's set up to
measure and say this person can do
something really magnificent with this
brain and this mind if we feed the right
information talking about two different
things what you've done is you've mixed
up physical and mental so you're totally
100% correct in saying that you could
look at that physique of a very
bodybuilder versus someone who's very
Sun School eat on you're not gonna
enlist I really I just done so there's a
physical thing that that lean that that
enables yes it is physical it is
physical so there's the physical that 1%
that shows that there's probably more
tendency for someone like you to become
a bodybuilder than like me to become a
bodybuilders just in terms of our
science ok so these the physique thing
that's the physical the other side is
you can look at a person's what they
saying what they doing what they seem to
be interested in that's what you say and
if they and if you shape that can you
can you and you expose them to the books
and the the main tools and or whatever
can you grow them in that direction
there isn't a way of measuring that with
the brain and I'm going to use AI
artificial intelligence to explain to
one neuron in the brain
it moves at a speed or fires at a speed
of 10 to the 16 one neuron okay
artificial intelligence is trying to
build a human brain that can do what a
human can do based on getting the firing
speed up to 10 to the 16 that's only one
neuron your brain is not made of one
neuron your brain is made of a hundred
billion neurons that's only 20% of brain
tissue the entire brain of those hundred
billion neurons they fire the speed of
10 to the 27 which is it's it's it's so
big it's incomprehensible so this so
that's the one but then there's all the
other parts of the brain that interact
now we see that the chemicals that then
impact this peasant impact the quantum
wave plays an impact by the time you've
built all those factors in your seats
absolutely impossible to do that the big
leader in this field has been a actually
also a South African a guy who's who
rendered the brain of the but the the
Blue Brain Project
and the change into another into another
name and basically gone blank now his
name is gonna come back in a moment
he basically his whole goal was to build
a network is his name again any walk
thank you
him Henry Markram his whole goal 30
years ago he makes the same university
as I did was to build an artificial
brain 12 years into into into the any
city of during 12 years a few short
years into the project now we're talking
about about a guy who raised billions of
euros billions of dollars teams of
scientists the base and he still runs
one of the biggest brain projects in the
world
he said and this is what makes him
brilliant as a scientist I made a
mistake my mistake was to think that we
could simulate the human brain in a
computer that we could make something
that's not not this physical structure
that we see into something that we could
predict and program and say this
person's there and then build that that
it's impossible he said of the city yes
after 30 years there's no project that's
bigger than his office 30 years of doing
this what they've managed to do with the
top scientists in the world is they'd
managed to simulate once one thought in
a mouse brain looking for cheese or
whatever and it's a veritable universe
so his argument and then these other
people like him often in Arizona and dr.
Sir Roger Penrose the mathematician is
at this time to said or like art their
scientist that are brilliant that have
shown that it is absolutely impossible
because once thought is a veritable
universe in a rat what are the thoughts
that you think you you you never stop
thinking you are constantly building new
thoughts every 10 seconds you are able
to consciously and deliberately capture
your thoughts there's no space that
you're going to run out of in your brain
in terms of the amount of thoughts and
it's all different there's no similar
we're all a bit crazy there's no one so
we can't get a model that says if you
have that type of model what we see is
behavior we see interest we see it for
kids I see you've got three kids I've
got four I see my one is much more
interested in in in Kannamma field so
that's what she went into University
another one who's totally into the
literature's another one who's turned
into the history side so as a parent we
we make sure that we expose our children
how
that's what we're talking about so then
you guide them and you give them the
opportunity so it's more creating
opportunity but there isn't a
reductionistic way neuro reductionism
has been burst out of the MRI movement
in the mid 90s where we could see inside
the brain and there was this love affair
that began we're saying that we can see
this in your brain this is the size
change this causes this and it's not the
truth an MRI 70% inaccurate I work with
Q equals 70 percent inaccurate it's not
it's full of 70 percent false positives
so claims forty thousand studies have
been done Ian on MRIs 70% of the the of
what they find is a false positive you
cannot say that this part of the brain
does this if I don't have anymore I
appear good and there's this part of the
brain does this phone is firing to show
the response in the brain so what we can
see on a very broad scale is a response
like I use QTE G's in my in my research
and a QE each is a very accurate way of
seeing active activation in the moment
so if I linked you up now to acute EEG
machine and I had my technicians analyze
what's going on both of us we would have
a lot of what we call high gamma
activity which is a wave that shows a
lot of insight deep thinking creatively
making a lot of links there's a lot of
thinking going on here if I was if we
linked it up that machine after someone
who's in chronic stress who has who is
just not who's waking up in the morning
back in to get through the day who's
just stuck in a pattern of negativity
and worry and it's better to make it
through every moment we would see very
little again the activity we would see
patterns and a changes every moment but
we would see a general pattern of
Highwood we call high high beta activity
and whatever so these certain patterns
but they don't they're not telling your
story
they just patterns their responses so
the brain tells us something is going on
it's like standing on a 20-foot building
the 20th floor of a hotel and downstairs
you see a group of people talking you
can't hear what they saying you can
maybe if you leaned over the balcony
over the window you can hear a little
bit of noise because noise carries but
you can then you see there's something
going on so you see these may be a fight
to an argument but you don't know the
detail of what's going on that's what
brain technology tells us it tells us
that the brain something's going on in
the brain the brain responds and the
brain
constantly changes the greatest
contribution brain technology has made
is that our brain constantly changes and
that's called neuro caster so often it's
changed now every second is changing
every experience is changing back in the
80s I was trained other t-talk ones I
was trained that the brain couldn't
change a challenge that I did work with
people that had traumatic brain injury
like major that had been written off by
neurologists and neurosurgeons and
through deliberate and intentional
building of the brain learning growing
the brain studying daily and working on
mind management for emotional start
doing this mind work the this and this
was one case went back to university
ended up finishing school getting high
grades and this was this kid had been
written off as a vegetable and I've seen
that happen way too often not just me
there's many scientists who have since
showing that when you use your mind your
brain will change now technologies
confirm that MRIs show us yes I'm
thinking your brain has changed it never
stays the same and that's the beauty of
humanity so you know always changing so
you don't fear AI threat at all not at
all it's fantastic it's just giving us
more insight so this whole thing about
AI is gonna replace all jobs and work
what you're saying it would never
couldn't even could just gonna make our
jobs easier we're going to have to be
smart in how we manage things it's it's
really it's like technology on phones
least if technologies managed it's a
tremendous asset to humanity it's only
when it's must managed that it becomes a
problem so AI is a way of like the first
quantum computers have already been both
and that's a great way of us being able
to understand knowledge and manage
knowledge more effectively it's how we
use the technology is always going to be
the issue it's how we use brain
technology that's going to be the issue
brain technology has been used badly for
Humanity in a lot of ways very good in a
lot of ways because it's given us a lot
about I mean I through technology I've
learnt about the brain but it certainly
doesn't tell you about how you as a put
okay let me finish if the brain fires up
and you are looking at a painting and
someone else is going through a tumor
you you conceive that firing in your
brain I can't tell you if that firing is
because you've had a tumor or and you re
experiencing a PTSD or you are looking
at a beautiful painting because the same
kind of firing happens in the brain okay
television she's gone till tonight Gosei
happy thank you sit over here okay and
you have this Q ug whatever you got on
my on my brain okay and we have
different things that are coming behind
you you can't see what I'm looking at
right yeah you cannot find out what
nothing so these summons going on it's
very stimulated you can see very
stimulated there's a lot of activity I
differentiate between the difference you
can't you call these thoughts and that's
we what him one day we can or no I know
you can only predict from people's
behavior but and we'll get obviously
technology's going to advance but sure
not in a thousand times a thousand years
so therefore literally this is what
Henry Markram and and Hema HOF which of
the two leaders in this field they
really the leaders fighting the AI
movement in terms of not finding it in
terms of you must have develop and
technology but you need to be realistic
if one thought in a mouse brain is a
veritable universe how are many other
thoughts in your brain and what kind of
universe it's a universe your child in
your children your little girl she's a
universe of thoughts and you'll never
fully understand her you'll never fully
know or be able to predict how she's
gonna react tomorrow you can estimate
but you will always be quantum physics
shows that said you can know your wife
you can know your child you can know
your husband but you can you still be
30% inaccurate if I don't know you over
well I've only watched you on new
interviews so I'm gonna guess but I'm
going to be 50% inaccurate I know my
husband very well because I've been
married for 32 years I can guess but I'm
still gonna be only 70% in that region
accurate so we thought solid thoughts
the effect is this beautiful
part of humanity that we need respect
and it can always change so if someone
has done something and they've been
doing it for more than 63 days they have
wired attack me into their brain like a
pathway it looks like a toxic tree
that's why use this it's a real protein
to all computers and those computers
have been very very established it takes
21 days to build a long-term memory
it takes 63 days minimum to build a
habit not to anyone like we've been told
anything after that you're going to
expert level so if I have for six years
been worrying I'm an expert warrior it
doesn't mean that you I am it's who I've
become so I can unbe come it's hard work
I'm gonna have to do a lot of mind
management to use emotional signals like
depression and anxiety and schizophrenia
and all that stuff omission st spoke
about I'm gonna have to use that to make
to find out what is the cause of why I'm
so negative how did you find out about
63 instead of 21 days
that's memory research I'm putting about
it also netbook thing blue and succeed
so it's basically what we see is your
brain your body works in cycles of
healing so if you have a blister you'll
find that it takes for example 30 21
days to moralize maybe could be training
streaker between it could be 19 but it's
in that region we see that it takes
cycles of that to heal dr. Marian
diamond who died last year at 84 one of
the leading researchers in this
particular field of memory she showed
how the little branches that are made of
millions of computers that hold them
your memories as vibrations on the tops
of the trees that over time the the
branch has changed shape and it takes 21
days for the branches to reach a certain
shape and when they reach that certain
shape they made of proteins that are
what we call self-sustainable so we see
a change in proteins some proteins are
very unstable they only last for 24 48
hours some only last 7 days some 14 days
some 21 days so we can see that that's
the kind of what we're talking about we
can see a change and a progression now
even a long-term memory can be
reconceptualized
and that means I'll always remember so
let's say for example someone is the
half loss in 1000 sees the glass half
empty and they've just been in that and
it's just like oh these people just
always gonna see the negative first
every meet the business meeting they
just always see the negative but that
person can change their very world they
become an expert in being negative but
they can actually unwire that they can
they can get to the point where it's a
lot of work but you've got to go through
the pain of doing it which people don't
want to in this day and age and that's
something we should maybe discuss but
you can change that and reverse that
process then one day that guy in your
meeting you'll say wow you actually see
okay I'm gonna show you how I'm gonna
talk about that in a moment so that guy
will actually then say hey now I am you
just did something positive so Patrick
says to the business employee hey you
actually seen this differently what did
you do it
whatever what does that person done that
person has seen the response of and I'm
just using this because it'd be boarded
up first of your colleagues his
colleagues his boss etc getting kind of
a little bit put off by the negativity
we all know you around someone negative
it can impact you because they're
generating toxic photons and whatever so
they by looking at the response and the
feedback they make a choice that's the
initial start process so once I
recognize okay people don't you know I
need to do something it's either either
feedback from people or I can't go on
like this anymore I'm burning out stress
wise I'm getting sick because there's a
relationship between chronic ongoing
inflammation and physical illnesses in
your body which I've just done research
on now and the mind stuff and how you
can change that so what does person does
first is an awareness it's it's
embracing it either from feedback or
from I can't go on like this anymore so
there's some level of awareness I've got
embrace step number one embrace
acknowledge it's all the same thing
I've got to get to the point where I'm
going to do that and in the in that is
the choice okay I want to change I don't
want to have this feedback in I want to
improve my relationship I don't want to
keep living a life where I'm always
worrying or always anxious it's making
me sick which it is which it does so
that's the first tip embrace acknowledge
and choose then you've got to go through
a very painful process of processing and
that is a process of why do I do this
why am I always negative and it's a
process it's an exercise where you
literally go through five steps for 30
minutes a day and I always recommend to
my patients and my research has shown
stick around thirty minutes and 45
minutes is pushing it because it's heavy
stuff when you start digging into trauma
Oh dealing with your toxic habits it's a
theory draining so you've got to limit
that otherwise the whole day it becomes
this big emotional washout and you
become very I focus which is very
unhealthy for your heart more the more
times you say I me and mine you're going
to increase your chance by 42% at having
a cardiovascular event in the next 12
months so we don't want to turn people
into cells because of the stroke I'm in
mind pressures all on you it's on me
you're putting it inside you focusing on
yourself you go around in so of course
you don't get perspective
you've got to have interaction with
others you've got to have deep
meaningful relationships so the more
sulfur focused you become the more your
heart becomes strained your blood
vessels start going your body goes into
toxic stress your blood vessels around
your heart constrict you reduce oxygen
and blood flow to your brain and you're
set yourself up for cardiovascular so
the more you I mean by myself or III
isolation individualism the more you're
going to die which is what we see in
this day and age we see an increase in
cardiovascular events in the United
States in UK in developed countries that
have an individualistic focus we see way
less in countries that have a community
focus like Japan and you know the the
various different countries that have
more of a community focus this country
is the most individualized country one
of the most individualized countries or
use or the loneliest in the world and we
have one of the highest rates of people
dying from isolation cardiovascular
disease etc annually and I mean this is
becoming a problem in as much of a
problem as the UK Australia the
developed countries we see more and more
where we see more community like in
Africa Cambodia those we see less and
less of that we see people dying from
malnutrition and hygiene and that kind
of stuff but we don't see them dying
because they'll only this country people
are nutrition they they healthy they
will feed they are successful Kate Spade
they are beautiful they and they
committing suicide they you don't saying
these so we've got a problem they so
coming back to the question you asked me
how someone changes we've got to do this
what's the five stuff so the five steps
first of all is gather gather gather
that's a big word for embrace
acknowledge embrace that your embrace
that you have an issue stuff that's like
a you know your first acceptance quietly
accept is an issue what's the second one
second one is you've got to reflect it's
a deep reflection it's a process this is
the most painful part it's it's like a
surgeon will say my friends I've got lot
of doctor friends and they'll say that
they've got to first cut up the patient
to heal them so you got to go through
the pain before go to hurt you to heal
you so that's a very it's this whole
process is hard I'm not applying it but
it's good and it takes time it's going
to take cycles of 21 days so the second
process is deep reflection where you are
basically trying to
Trek back to not necessarily bet but why
am I doing this when you study in your
trends you're looking at your trains
your patterns so the first thing is to
start is to take okay this I'm depressed
this is an emotional warning signal your
body's got physical warning signals so
you're embracing the emotional and
physical warning signals from the
environment and from yourself you then
thinking about these okay so why am I
always negative
why am I always depressed why am i
anxious and as you go through that
process of self-reflection you're
getting to the point where you're not
where you just wanna find get to it's
there every day it's a little bit to the
point where you find okay well maybe
this is at the end of 21 days you see oh
I'm anxious because I'm actually trying
to be a perfectionist I'm trying to
control everything in my environment and
it's not quite working out or maybe it's
because there's a tumor that you've
never dealt with you've kept yourself so
busy trying to suppress the tumor that
it's actually made you whatever it's
going to be different for it when
there's no pattern and there's no link
between if I've had sexual trauma and
heart disease or something people have
tried to do that they've tried to show
that if you've got a go better issue
it's anger this is just not science at
all this is just guessing games because
someone who's angry could have
gallbladder issues and they could have a
cardiovascular should it's different for
each person
it's so our genome is unique my fetchers
unique gather then you have reflect pain
then the third thing is we've got a
genetically process so what we've got to
do is you've got to make your brain do
stuff people right the third process is
right when you write you're clearing out
a lot of and when I say right it's like
literally throw it on the page because
you'll see my sequence that I've
developed you literally spend a minute
and a half to two minutes doing each of
these so you would gather for a minute
and a half you would reflect for a
minute and a half you would write for a
minutes and a half a little bit longer
if you want to and then you would
recheck now reach ik is a process where
you go back and look for patterns your
triggers you do your what does this mean
so if you think of it I've become aware
of something going on negative half loss
worry anxiety I am reflecting why am I
feeling I'm starting to get to the red
crystal on your minutes and a half and
you must move
you're writing that dance maybe a bunch
of jumble that you write down you
recheck looks at your jumbo and chance
to get some level of order you were then
you go to you get to educate that level
of audience okay what's my little tiny
task for today and it may be as simple
as when I feel this anxiety coming on
I'm gonna I'm gonna compartmentalize it
and I'm gonna only worry about it
tonight at six o'clock so it could be a
simple statement long number four that's
that's number four leading to number
five so number four is retakes I see
that I'm always worrying in certain
situations but in a minute and a half is
only a little bit of information you've
gathered which is the point you must
only get a bit every day not everything
every day we consult all Rome was not
built in a day it's little things change
over time we try and fix it quickly you
can't get there it's a process you have
to dig it out of your non-conscious it's
a deep investigative detective process
that you're doing so let's say now that
you start seeing okay I'm worrying
because of this or- and I'm starting to
get a glimpse of well maybe it could be
this or maybe so what can I do today
there's a little activity activity after
the active reach an active reach is then
if I see that evil it's like the
worrying thing I just I wake up in the
morning just like that day I'm stuck at
skiing so I said okay I'm aware that I'm
worrying all I've worked out today today
one I've just read after that then I
actually need us don't worry so cool
what's my extra reach I as I worry as
that hits me in the fear in the face I'm
going to say okay this worry I can't
deal with now I'm gonna deal with
tonight so now it's six o'clock in the
morning I'll do that six o'clock tonight
as you go through the day it is that
also what happens is you take the energy
away from the worry now you must
remember that well I haven't even told
you this much clearly but every thought
you build is a real living thing it has
energy its firing energy so if I take
this worry toxic and I say okay keep
quiet you in a box I'm not gonna deal
with it and you will discipline yourself
not to think about it and by the time
six o'clock tonight comes twelve hours
later
that thing's lost energy most likely
they're gonna be powerful what you just
said right there because I out this with
a lot of guys where you know
your brain automatically is going to
prom I can't believe this person said
this I can't believe we're facing this
oh my gosh look what's going on this is
gonna be so much bigger you know this is
terrible set it aside six hours later
don't give it any weight don't give it
any power six hours you're not even
thinking about this today's the science
behind it so the science is that of you
but if you don't think about growth so
that worry and also whatever you don't
think about whatever you don't think one
grow whatever you think about growth so
these things feed on energy so if I keep
thinking about that all day long I'm
getting myself in a toxic mix you get
stuck that's why we have to do with Tomo
we have to deal with our habits because
they keep us stuck we've got to get them
out and change them so if I put that by
the end of the evening this thing is
lost were even tomorrow once once a week
you can have your little worried neck
boys talks about having a little my
husband he has like in his mind mentally
there's a little worried book and
Thursday afternoon at 4 o'clock
storybook time
everything goes in that poky allows
himself one day a week to worry about it
and by the time he gets it doesn't
happen anymore now what's happening
scientifically is that research shows
that 95% of all worries don't
materialize anyway so by the time we get
there in the afternoon or next week or
whenever it is that you decide to worry
you actually it's lost its power over
you and so that's just a little
technique and that's typical of a lot of
reach now what I did with my patients is
our developers technique it's been
clinically tested scientifically
researched physically applied was pretty
materials but we've just released an
ethanol way I've put this because people
have been asking me for years
I don't do therapy anymore I don't have
time I teach this around the world so
now I've put all of us into a mobile
apps so on your phone in a mobile
application so it's literally therapy
well called switch switch switch switch
switch your months you're gonna put the
link below if you're watching this we're
gonna put the link below for the app so
you can go download it and test it for
yourself you switch switch with iTunes
Google Play with it and that basically
walks you through these five steps Audio
driven and then I have little things on
there like if you're having a panic
attack
maybe you got to go into meeting you can
press play and don't be able to talk
about meditation then yeah would be
gonna get the app orgasm download yeah
let's talk about that so it's so next
thing so for me a few things that you
see a lot that's coming up recently is
all the medication that we being asked
to take right I have kids and I'll live
you know how to meeting ghosts you know
your son doesn't really pay attention in
the class and he's kind of struggles
with you know you know a present and
he's always dozing off and he's going
different places and I say yeah it's my
son he reminds me a little bit of myself
when I was that age so from from your
perspective whether we're dealing with
bipolar ADHD depression panic how much
of that is part of our perception which
is how we're born
I'm born being bipolar I'm born having
ADHD how much of it is imagination I
think I have this how much of it is
somebody else imposing their belief on
you and how much of it is real question
okay so now we're dealing with something
cool that falls in the realm of mental
illness and it's a complete misnomer
because we told that mental illness
number one to answer question is on the
rise and that we've got more and more
kids that need to be identified with all
these these bipolar theatres etc but
actually mental illness is not on the
rise what's happened is we have
mismanagement of mind that has created a
whole new problem so what we have in
issue here is that mental illness
doesn't actually exist now hear me
carefully
I'm not saying that depression isn't
real I am saying it's incredibly real
schizophrenia psychotic breaks bipolar
these things are very real but they're
not illnesses they're not physical
illnesses in your brain you don't have
bipolar waiting to jump out and ADHD
waiting to jump out and which is where
the neurobiological your reductionistic
biomedical neuropsychiatric model which
is all these things for the same thing
or going what the truth is is that
you're 99% mind we have to deal with
that 99% mind which is how you are
dealing with what you're going through
in life as its own separate category
when we talk about the physical brain
and body you have weaken test if you've
got a cardiovascular disease if you've
got diabetes if you've got a traumatic
brain injury you in a car accident to me
see if you've got tumors in your brain
if you've got liver disease if you've
got fatty liver disease whatever we can
do biological tests where we can blood
test we can do various different tests
to identify and treat it works that's
called the biomedical model and it
works for the physical brain and body
it's excellent however in this in about
60 years ago in and it really hit in the
80s that whole category got blended and
people's mind issues gotta stop being
called mind issues and sort of thing
called illnesses against many scientists
and being anti that but a movement began
because it's not accurate because you
can't call something like something why
why did it go from you know illness is
it because the business part in a minute
business so in an amid a so in in the
50s or zine was the first psychotropic
to be developed as a Thorazine program
that's other name is called primacy so
there's an anti-psychotic it's called an
anti-psychotic must named an
anti-psychotic it's an NSC anaesthetic
so what it did was have calm people done
so what we had in the 50s more or less
this first drug came out it was used
many people with mind issues have always
been badly handle it there's a historic
we've just done bad job there's been
pockets of good things that have been
done in between but in general people's
mind issues have not been handled well
but in in the in the 50s this drug was
developed and they took they gave they
actually gave it my mistake to some
patients in a mental asylum and they
seemed to calm down and they became more
manageable and so gave birth to this the
psychiatric drug industry and by the mid
80s we had prozac then we had the second
generation drug but before we know it we
had every psychotics antidepressants
anti-anxiety made the famous you know
Librium and Penix and these things that
are now household names and every second
person is on some sort of drug so what
we have is an industry that was given
birth to called the psychotropic drug
industry and it was basically very
financially driven and I mean everything
I said can back up scientifically and
there's hundreds of scientists thousands
actually there that and you'll find
references in all my work so essentially
what we have is an industry that says ok
if you're feeling sad depressed
up-and-down psychotic breaks can't cope
etc you are ill so therefore you need a
drug because if you ill likely have
cardio basically you need a drug so they
had a theory
got a few years ago just after Perez you
know whatever he said well maybe it's a
chemical imbalance in the brain and so
the hunt began to see ah it's in the
brain and it became a whole thing where
you've got to find a neurobiological
correlate for the disease so they then
shifted everything from you as a human
in life going through the scenarios if
you spoke about in the beginning going
through whatever scenario going to war
going to whatever everything life the
human condition people in life that was
taken out of the equation
you know I factor your experience your
narrative your story your context your
life taken away and you were seen if you
were sad or depressed for longer than
two weeks because you just lost some
wherever you're not your story that
didn't count what counts is that your
feelings said according to the
Diagnostic and Statistical Manual which
is not at all statistical scientific I
know the people involved in the
development I know a lot about the DSM
and it's not a scientific manual it's
good for firewood and that's about it
you really mean it's good for fire
doorstop firewood but definitely not to
label and limit people because what
we're doing there is we're taking the
concept of if you have fatty liver
disease we've got a diagnostic category
we can fix it we can they've tried to do
that with mine now let me ask you this
if you have just lost your wife I'll
give you a classic example I was in
teaching the San Tomas islands just
recently doing I mean I do a lot of
mental health conferences all over the
world and this woman came after me after
me teaching on mind and brain all the
stuff that I teach on and she she had
just lost her husband in the previous
hurricane in 2017 her husband's head was
severed literally in front of her from
the hurricane breaking and hitting the
whatever through whatever building and I
don't know the exact details everyone
knows that she was there and she lost
her husband she's young young mom you
can imagine the trauma you never get
over that number one that told me you'd
never get over let me say that you don't
get over trauma
you don't get over grief you get through
it you don't get over it you don't get
to it you learn how to move forward
through it and we shouldn't take that
away because there is her story this
woman came up to me after the session
and she said dr. V if I wanted to and
she was smiling I'm thinking this is
some great story she's gonna and she
proceeded to tell me the story instead
she was seeing to a doctor after the
school
she was obviously I mean I wouldn't how
do you cope with something like that the
doctor said you've got bipolar you've
got a clinically you view clinically
depressed by polio clinically depressed
you need an antidepressant she said I am
NOT clinically depressed I do not have
an illness I have just lost my husband
who passed her over church whatever gave
gave him one of my books which was I
mean if this is the story she told me
and she said she decided to start doing
that five steps that I've just done and
she processed and went through and
experienced her grief she she cried she
screamed she shouted she saw you have to
freak out in that zone you have to get
once you acknowledge I'm in grief this
is my story I'm not gonna make this is
not an illness that's an insult to tell
someone who's been through war grief a
child is bullied or a child who's
betting to learn who needs to just be
helped to learn or maybe who's been
given a decent diet or who's been
bullied at school and who's having an
emotional reaction is it fair to tell
that person she has a label you have
ADHD ADHD is not even a scientific
category I've worked in learning
disabilities for 25 years in my practice
and done research in this area 2 to 17
percent of people have a learning
disability from a booth tumor or
something going on in the womb or some
kind of a head injury we have a seventy
to seventy seven percent plus going up
referral rate for people with a DD every
second person's got ADHD including
adults it's not even a real thing what
we have is a society that's very busy we
designed to do busy well that people
aren't managing technology we're not
managing online we have been told as a
society which is where we started this
discussion literally at the beginning
we've been told as a society that you
are your brain your brain is controlling
you so therefore bipolars in your brain
and you are not a believer not at all my
pearl is gonna move through your brains
so now this woman has grief she's seen
her husband's head sliced off she's in
terrible tumour from that and from the
fact that he's lost her husband then
experience went through her brain so
obviously there's a toxic thought in her
brain that's a toxic experience that is
a torment an involuntary trauma because
as a human everything new process goes
in your brain it becomes a structure you
change your brain you are always growing
your brain that's neuroplasticity your
brain structures changing every moment
of every day so of course she
that of course her heart was affected
she nearly died from from from
cardiovascular issues because of the
fact that your heart is impacted through
so in other words your brain and body of
course they're gonna respond of course
you're gonna have physical of course you
need a medical doctor to help mint
monitor Ida lady the other day at a
conference I did she's wearing a heart
monitor she just lost her husband she's
not coping she's really betting they put
she's they had a couple of thrills but
almost heart attack so now she walks
down with her so yes your brain and body
will respond so we will see the effects
of trauma in your brain we and some
people will be in mood swings some
people it will be complete withdrawal
but depression bipolar anxiety these are
so real they the 99% we need to give
them more attention so are you saying if
I don't have if if John doesn't have any
symptoms of bipolar a traumatic a
traumatic experience to him could give
him symptoms of what a doctor could
consider him him to have him bipolar
I'm not being bipolar well basically
they these certain questions that are
asked you know I've never been diagnosed
I've been a regular kid I'm good I fall
in love with the girl we marry each
other one day were walking she slips
somebody comes up they shoot her right
in front of me dies they miss me i watch
her die right in front of me I can't do
anything about it for the rest of my
life I feel guilty can I go from being
normal prior to that to afterwards now I
got some kind of symptoms where a
psychologist could say I think you've
got certain issues you okay so what we
need to do is ignore is what that
person's gone through that person has a
story that what you've just described as
a personal story that's the 99% of what
they've experienced we need to validate
that by hearing them by listening to
them we invalidate that by saying you
have an illness of clinical depression
we invalidate that by saying that okay
99% okay you see it's only 1% I'm not
gonna validate to experience and they
second tell you you have a brain illness
you do not have a neuropsychiatric brain
disease you have a terrible trauma and
we need to listen to you we need to help
you you need community you need to cry
mask you let me be the devil's advocate
in this how much it I can also be used
by somebody to use that as a crutch to
say
this is why I'm not doing that well a
lot of people's yeah you know this is
why I'm also that's what I'm saying it's
stuck you have to read conceptualize so
we're not talking about the five steps
and I talked about acknowledging you
know that gather think write recheck and
active rich what you're doing there is
Yuri conceptualizing so you're changing
so here you've gone through the track
this woman who went through that seeing
her husband's head severed she now does
grief counseling for people that are
going through grief so she still has
days where she cries and breaks down
she's a human it's the human condition
it's a response to the suffering of life
we click on medicalised Missouri pair to
be caught the thought of John's pain
emotional pain trauma these are stories
that are part of your suffering they
kind of you the King the Japanese have a
beautiful principle called consider if
you ever heard of it that's brilliant if
a vase drops or a beautiful porcelain
pot and it shatters all over the ground
most people just sweep it away and throw
it away what we see what they do is they
actually rebuilds that a long it takes
they rebuild the whole pot and they use
a lacquer filled with gold and platinum
so they rebuild something beautiful with
with the the gold showing that what it
did the damage so in other words that's
what become weary conceptualize so now
the swoon with the grief she has the pot
she's a pot of gold she's rebuilt her
life but the pain is still there we
don't want it not acknowledge she
remembers the pain but she's now
managing the pain by moving fooled by
helping others by not just me myself and
I she's got to have periods of me myself
and I but you've got to have balance
that there are periods of going out of
yourself so you have to reconceptualize
which means redesign see it have you
it's okay to grieve you should grieve
you know what the DSM says if you that
woman after two weeks if she didn't if
she was still grieving
she now has an illness you tell me you
can agree the rest of your life that
that happened to wife you're never going
to get through grief the worst thing you
can say to someone who is grieving is
time will heal thumb does not heal
you'll get over you will not get over
you don't believe that no you will learn
to live with it that's the first thing
you've ever experienced you attempted
suicide no family by very close family
member which is and it was unsuccessful
but it was how many years ago was
perfect four years ago four years ago
I've had a my oldest daughter nearly
died of bulimia I mean I'm in the field
I'm in the moment you literally you as a
parent you completely like how do you
cope with something like that you it's
devastating but you have a choice
because I have to stay strong and wise
for my kids so I freaked out I cried I
saw I did whatever but I had a sense of
peace in me then I will be strong and I
will be then I will help my child
through so I hadn't suppress it I didn't
go into a state where I couldn't cope
anymore and got diagnosed have those
medications antidepressants etc those
don't heal anything they damage the
brain so people experience a period of
help because they numb the brain so if
I'm in a place where I where you've got
that grief for your husband or whatever
your child daily dying of bulimia
whatever you whatever dwarma you're in a
bad place and some and what they do
those those drugs will numb the pain
because sometimes it pains too much but
you know what we have to be brave we
have to allow ourselves and give us
those permission to go through the pain
and we can't do it alone pedals are the
other thing what we see from science is
that as a family we pulled together when
my when my daughter went through that
that terrible time when that woman went
through the grief with her husband she
had a community as soon as I reach out
to universe until you your brain changes
you know that you switch on you actually
switch on a genetic switch in your brain
that increases your resilience when
you're in community you also change how
your neurotransmitters flow your entire
body works for you instead of against
you the blood will dilate and you'll
have more blood in your brain and oxygen
in your brain 1,400 neuro physiological
responses will work for you in that
state even in the midst of your
screaming shouting crying swearing going
crazy expressing going from highs to
lows which is all normal you have got
this inner strength that sets happening
when you realize that okay I give myself
permission to go through this and I and
I'm going to do it I'm not going to be
alone no one can fix you no one can take
your pain away but I can hold your hand
and that's what we need to do sucker
Lord of the Rings Frodo Sam say to Frodo
I can't carry the ring into Mount Doom
but I can't carry you and this is what
how we have to manage mental health we
to allow people to embrace and process
and we have to do it in community not
medicate not drug you have you have for
25 years who practice do you have the
ability to prescribe me any medication
no I don't prescribe a lot of
prescribing physician you're not nice do
you have the ability to tell me go see
dr. Jones she can prescribe you a Zoloft
she can prescribe you rebel and she can
prescribe I would never kill you like
this because you've never in your life
recommended ever I actually put people
on withdrawal programs to get off the
drugs those drugs increase your chance
of dementia they have no positive
effects except numbing effects so the
only time that I would indicate it says
someone is now in met with severe tumor
and they they they are freaking out
maybe someone's like freaking to do
something dangerous
maybe 24-hour sedation but then you've
got it but not longer than that because
these drugs are addictive their drugs
they're not medicine they're not healing
your body they damaging your body
they're not medicine it's very very
powerful they set you up for the
dimensions they have three thousand four
side effects and all the technical
trials have actually been have shown
that they're not effective they cherry
pick they take out and they say they
worked over perceiver they did not it's
not the accurate truth the public hasn't
been presented with the truth obviously
I know a lot of these because in my
world I have a lot of peers they we talk
openly whether it's lorazepam
you know adderall you know adderall is a
very big thing nowadays people are
getting hooked on adderall very early on
from high school or this guy can't pay
attention to school here take some
adoramatv just drive that's how early
they started how hard it is annex in the
wound say that again they are doing
they're off they're medicating babies in
the womb now saying that from a brain
scan that this baby's potential to get
to fit yeah that's how that's how the
public can be lied to it's financially
driven the kids as young as two doctors
are doing this around the globe it's the
worst in the United States of America
you can't also the other thing is you
can't just like these guys you're
talking about you can't just stop these
drugs because as if it drug you in your
mouth your brain changes you've gross
things in your brain when you take an
antidepressant and antipsychotic reason
you actually grow structures in your
brain that damage your brain the guy
behind me the one day
your husband was talking about how the
shop at one time was interviewed on BBC
he says the difference between us and
the West is the West is you know wasting
life by taking away too many sleeping
pills any citizens 76 he talked about it
so it's like you know you're you're
putting yourself through your problem by
just medicating yourself not even
thinking about the timing naming the
numbing your brain to not even go
through the problem let me go through
what you said okay so this is a
festering wound when you think and feel
and choose you call genetic expression
you grow stuff in your brain that should
be doing now we've been talking about
this if you have a toxic issue in you
haven't dealt with it you have this
thing the proteins are all folded
weirdly the electrical chemical balance
is wrong it's all dangerous here's a
slide to show you what it looks like
they it actually it's not a hole it's
actually toxicity this is like a virus
so if I don't deal with this if I just
medicate that medication grows extra
things around this area that make it
worse so when the know in the numbing
effect wears off I've got this and I've
got now extra things here that make my
brain and that's aggressions manifesting
feelings of worse depression aggression
etc then if you just put the medication
back on we say positive affirmation and
happiness industry you're just
presenting a band-aid on the wound is
still festering eventually it'll burn
right through we have to get it out and
researchers as soon as we get it out in
the conscious as soon as you gather we
can see how this is striking you
actually weaken it you weaken the bonds
which means you can redesign it very
powerful yep I agree a a brilliant
concept next question
people have faced different challenges
in their lives okay you just talked
about suicide I've experienced exact
similar situation to where I had to call
the cops they came they took the person
went to the hospital because there was
too many calls of suicide at one point
this person took 17 sleeping pills at
the same time and said hey I love you I
said this is too many calls I just
called bomb Co pick them up once
straight to us but I want to visit it
the person very close family
messes with your head because you're
always worried about this person killing
you killing themselves and you don't
have any control over it right so we got
loss of a loved one we're pretty much
all gonna experience this no longer we
live we're gonna experience it the tough
part is a different loss of a loved one
is burying your parents versus burying
your child
it's a different kind of a pain from
your experience if you don't mind if I
go through these you give me 15 30
seconds per because if we go longer we'd
be here for a long time for this you've
said what a lot of people what have the
immediate pain been for people that have
experienced this if you don't know if
you have an experience something like
this just a pass you know we'll go to
the next person or is the same thing
what's loss of a loved one been from a
parent burying their kids totally as a
tool where they can go in to troll with
a parent is that what you look yes yeah
you're going to go into trauma net in
itself is not it's too much and it's
real and people have to learn to move
forward through it so that's not ever
going to go away and that's what we need
to give people permission to keep that
because then grief eventually becomes a
point where you can actually take the
trauma and remember the good times and
that's been my experience working with
people that have lost a child through
suicide or early days for whatever
reason is that there's initially all the
stages you go through anger the denial
that hey you have to allow the process
and you have to very we've got to get
people through the sooner you actually
experience the pain you learn to then
manage the pain the sooner you cry
scream so now with the people don't try
and block that we in a day in an age
where it's okay you in pain let me
number let's get you sleeping tablets
you can't sleep it's better to stay
awake all night crying and cry that I
took it I'd have people around you
holding you just holding you that
physical contact and then every day it
will get a little bitter but if you
don't if you just shoved it away with
drugs you it the rest of your life has
any transform that I've got to say one
more thing pictures you go to transform
at some point like that woman whose
husband he'd got say that she
transformed their pain into activity
with people deep meaningful connections
she counsels people with grief now the
same thing as well she lost her husband
from a shooting yeah
so how about from all of these I think
based on the answer you give it may be
the same answer for all of them divorce
separation similar answer you would say
trauma strong yes close thing about
DuBose if I may say because there's the
connection because there's the whole
connection between a husband and wife
and the sexual connection everything
there's a lot of these these physical to
particles in quantum physics as soon as
they put in relationship
they no matter how far apart that ways
in relationship that's what quantum
physics is there's always a way there's
always a relationship yes so what you've
got here is now you've got the severing
of a relationship so now we've got this
this weird real thing so it has to be
healed so that's why it's so important
it's through communication through
talking through each other if it's
possible if it's not possible because
the person is hurting you know there's
abuse or something like that oh you know
it's too traumatic
then counselling with other people that
you get to a point where you can forgive
forgiveness is vital because it isolates
otherwise this this is the toxic divorce
there is we can see a physical thing
there's a quantum energy connection so
there's an invisible connection so if
you don't forgive even if you the victim
you still stay connected so by forgiving
us we sever their - we sever that
connection and that's vital in divorce
any kind of trauma even if someone's
raped you you've got to get to the point
where you forgive your not forgiving
what they've done what they did is
unforgivable but your forgiving from you
because now you're consider and you can
heal all that will control you the rest
of your life so you could seal this
thing off and redesign it does it make
sense of course
close call if I was almost died it
really messed with my head if somebody
had a close call of dying yeah I guess
um when somebody almost killed me
gunshot to my head we were bumped and I
almost died I'm shocked that stays with
me certain sirens always things PTSD so
you've got you know there is a sort of
illness it is a response so bipolar PTSD
all these things these are just umbrella
terms descriptions for the underlying
thing in this case you would experience
the reaction you experienced in your
whole body
it was embodied in your body so your
brain both the network your body
embodied it and then there's the trigger
so what you have to do is learn to
manage the triggers and that's a matter
of as you see them happening right or
down put it in your phone whatever and
then you can eventually learn to manage
those triggers what also happened in
those near-death experiences is very
often tremendous insight into your
spiritual nature
grab and run with that because that will
grow you as a person and you've got your
food find that with people that have
gone through those sexual abuse sexual
abuse is in very calm
complete invasion that starts with
acknowledgment very often it's
suppressed because of the guilt and the
shame that's surrounded it you know the
media movements helped a lot but for
male and female
this human that shame has locked people
in if we have a society that's more open
to allowing us to express how we feel
we're in a society that doesn't allow us
to express we need to be able to express
when you talk is the same thing you can
you've got to get it out you go to
process and then you've gotta forgive so
you've got to do that forgiveness it's
it's that fast a person for someone's
rage was you know this person was a kid
hey I was only six years old when it
happened I was 12 years old kind of
control do I have over it nothing until
later on and very often it only
manifests in a relationship later on you
can find that you know very often you'll
find in a relationship or in a
behavioral issue maybe early on so it's
picked up on that there's a change in
behavior and a child through place
therapy very often that can be picked up
and then it's a matter of helping
children to build a feeling of safety
and then it's as they're getting older
once they get into relationship it's
it's going to come back again and then
it's been creating an environment very
open that we've done with our kids in
our home is to talk about stuff but it
takes a lot of time what you've got to
do is create an openness in homes
amongst parents and children and in
society where all of us are experiencing
trauma it's the human condition you're
not different because you depressed
you're not different because you
sexually abused everyone has got a story
and more people abused and should be
it's very high numbers but society
doesn't allow us to talk about it so to
open with the safe community to be able
to talk about that I mean I can see that
so how about a loss of relevance Beauty
Fame you were popular you were
attractive now you've lost it used to be
the one that everybody gave you
attention used to be very popular you've
lost that so you went from being the
face and now you're no longer you've got
a lot of attention how do you deal with
that okay so first of all we have to go
and ask ourselves see if it's if it's
totally thrown you then we've taken that
external and we've taken the external
and we've put it on us and that's given
us our feeling of success but our
identities kind of lost so it's -
success is not that that wasn't really
success if she wasn't even successful
you choose
if success changes you your your your
identity it wasn't strong notes to
success is if you've got nothing and you
still feel a sense of peace in the midst
of the crisis so it comes from in terms
of spiritual thing very spiritual and
its internal its intrinsic versus
extrinsic and we're in an extrinsic a
dominated society here's a weird one
let's see what you're gonna say to this
I had a friend of mine who used to go
through a Catholic Church and a guy that
ran to church the priest was respected
by everybody and one day he flipped and
he says you know what I got three women
here in the church that I've been seeing
and I'm not who you think I am and I
have no desire to become a religious
leader that you base now what would John
do what would Bobby do what would Larry
do how do you manage I've had so many
friends that look I used to belong to
church when the pastor got up so were
called when the pastor got up he said
this how do you mean how do you deal
with that well we be putting people on
pedestals and we all it's it's a level
playing field we've gotta stop doing
that there's this whole thing I'm a
leader sound perfect you know if someone
what we should be doing is embracing
that priest honesty that he actually has
been put in a box of that celibacy we
should embrace the honesty and second
least he's actually come out and he's
actually been honest and I would go that
angle there's a lot of that there's a
lot of that yeah there's a lot of that
with that but he put people in boxes and
they can't live up to identity kills
people people more suicides happen from
people's lack of identity than anything
else if you did your density of you one
fan-dude
what do you put what did you go to
exactly that's a part of it public
humiliation yet a massive public
humiliation moment nowadays that happens
on social media you had a screw-up you
posted a picture and boom reappears 12
years that looks at totally forgot I
posted on Facebook 12 years ago I can't
believe I did that
you know I I had an incident on my
company I some happen people saw what I
did a very embarrassing moment how do
you handle that you can't control it I
got just just yesterday i sat with a
person a very successful person she said
can I talk to you privately pulled me
aside I said yes
my brother's girlfriend fiance is a very
famous online celebrity okay so I said
okay so I looked at the word person as I
know who this person is
see the face before okay this person
posted something that was not supposed
to happen everybody came after her she
lost 70 80 % she took a big hit okay
because her entire image that she was
selling it flipped and it was a wait a
minute you're talking about not shaming
you just shamed this individual mm-hmm
she doesn't have come back from this
major public humiliation that he had
because she Emilio did somebody else how
do you handle that so from a her
perspective from you made a big scrub
she knows she screwed up yeah and she is
not humiliated publicly because it's out
there there's nothing she can do about
it easy answer was rusty I made a
mistake
and that's people will still claim you
but that is absolute the vulnerability
authorization I used to think like this
and I've changed because of this people
respect that more than if I said that
earlier on about Henry Markram is a
great scientist one of the greatest
things about him was his ability to say
I was in the wrong direction I'm going
in another direction it's honestly it's
fun and we change change as humans and
we make mistakes
isn't those were they tell me one person
who hasn't made a mistake and if we
start owning up to our mistakes you're
not going to have the private issues
that we see so just if you make a
mistake and you've heard someone say
sorry and be honest my daughter's never
made a mistake a lot of mistakes and she
was famous said she screamed so loud the
entire neighborhood shuts down with this
girl screams well eating it out more
power than kosis you can sing one day
let's let's do something anybody she's
getting it out parenting your
relationships the last thing I want to
do and then we can wrap up from here is
men who are raised with a bad
relationship with mother don't make good
spouses okay you've heard this before
women who are raised without having a
father figure end up becoming dot dot
dot right how much truth is there behind
that Kevin O answer the same one that I
did earlier on nature nurture I factor
so you can have two people two kids in
the same home that have experienced that
kind of whatever so either of those
scenarios and one will go into a good
relationship one won't go into a good
relations relationship so once again
it's about it's definitely a fixed
nurturing does effect
is definitely gonna be issues so the one
that does succeed in the relationship
there's going to be things that they're
going to do that need to be dealt with
the whole thing here is embrace though
emotional rolling signals it's one of
the biggest things that I've told all my
patients and I say all the time is
listen to the emotional and physical
warning signals of your body which I've
been doing in my clinical research as
well and once you train yourself to do
that you can then bring that into your
see where it's like if you like you have
a great marriage but you've got this one
issue the other person's divorced five
times because of the parenting issue so
the one who's in the good marriage but
they've got this issue they say issue
deal with it use the signals that are
coming to feedback the emotional ones
the physical ones and make the changes
fair enough this one's another one that
I'm curious I know what you say about
this you know I watch how people are
raised okay and sometimes like I
interviewed Stephen Highsmith and
Stephen E Smith is a very famous sports
announcer I mean he's incredible sports
analyst okay he's incredible he works at
ESP spirit was the face of ESPN when he
talks people listen okay so how'd you
become the way you are today says my
mother never let me make an excuse every
time something bad happened he says she
says what could you have done
differently he's black he says my mother
never let me use my color as an excuse
she never let me once use race never let
me use this never interesting never and
anybody who does I see how he talked
about how Oprah Winfrey now this is this
person's like this because of this this
person killed somebody because of this I
am NOT this you killed somebody you kill
somebody you did this you did this okay
flipped on obvious you see got like this
that one straight to the top sometimes I
see you know the the parenting
philosophy and see if there's any
research you've done on this of my son
is perfect he can't do anything wrong
it's no way in the world my son no way
he sees perfect this kid is incredible
you know my grandson is incredible my
daughter no way in the world he didn't
do the wrong it's probably to teachers
probably somebody else what kind of
effect does that have on a kid when
parents are pitching this kid to be
perfect what does it do to us
psychologically they setting them up to
really experience them not hard knocks
and hopefully their child is going to as
they go through the hard
so learn the lessons and not perpetuate
that cycle of thinking cuz that's one of
those you know those genetic epigenetics
things that come through that is has
been woken up and they could continue
down the dinner it bit down the line but
there is they're pretty much sitting the
kids up to have real knocks for you
because it's not realistic because you
can't control anyone's choices you
cannot control your veins and
circumstances and you cannot control
other people's choices you can only
control your own reactions which is your
own thinking feeling and choosing which
I still don't get that dough but so I'm
pitching I'm presenting my kid to be
you're so perfect you can't this is an
incredible is the most incredible human
being I met in my life you know you're
so special you're amazing you're awesome
he doesn't make mistakes how does that
affect me negatively
isn't that a good thing to say that to
my kids no you don't want to say that
your kids all the time because it's not
realistic it's not a realistic thing
because they you love them for who they
are but you're setting a standard and
they're going to think well if I do any
if I fail which is every day you're
gonna make some mistake you're gonna
feel guilt and you're never going to
measure up to this you're always gonna
have an invalid
you will never measure up to the t's
affected you are density's effective you
sitting as well okay could it have an
impact of one a lack of commitment every
time commitment gets a little closer
even suicidal because if nothing
recognized valued for who you are humans
are designed to be valued I need to
value you for you I need a very my child
despite the choices that they make even
if I don't agree with a whole bunch of
them they are gonna make choices that I
don't agree with or that are wrong but I
still value who they are so you think me
telling you you're perfect as a form of
judgment it is because I've got a major
not up to what you think is to what you
think is perfection Wow you know what
that's the difference to you
yeah I mean but but initially it may
sound like a very noble thing you're
doing you know I'm not gonna make she
saying this is what I need you're fully
money you better fill my need it's very
selfish I like you this is very very
good I like you so have you seen the
movie the Pharaoh have you seen this new
movie that came out with the it's that
it's apparently a Chinese philosopher
where the grandmother has throat cancer
but apparently in China if you have a
illness that you're gonna die they don't
tell you about it so
came in they told hey the doctor said
his terminal illness but they came to
the grandma and said no you just got a
bad cough so the doctor says this lady's
got three to six months to live
you know I'm paraphrasing some of the
facts oh you don't want to three months
to live six years later she's still
living because she has no idea that she
has throat cancer how much do you
believe in that oh my gosh so much mine
is 99% not see we see with the work that
we do they're likely a mathematical team
in the research we do we see that that
if your mind is being managed and you
have a mindset that is one of single
portunities learning all the stuff
you've been speaking about that mind
will control the body because the mind
controls the body so we see people that
are on medication for cancer people that
have got these diagnoses and they live
beyond because of the attitude they
state of mind now they could that could
come from someone not telling you oh you
hear that you just you're not gonna
you're my mind said such that I'm gonna
make it you hear people that go through
chemo they have very mild chemo and they
get so many side effects other people
they get heavy chemo no side effects
drugs medication medication is only as
effective as you believe it is that
perception perception is that also part
of that perception
yes it drives the effectiveness girl
this what she's thinking right now
driving your genome your genome isn't
every soul so how you functioning
physically you making 800,000 cells
every second the quality is based on
your perception your effector your mind
this think feel choosing you think
there's a genius in all of us I do I do
believe it and it's different it's
different for everybody
do you believe there is a link between
madness and success absolutely because
what is madness so these definitely you
know everyone's a little crazy yeah I
would agree with that
and do you think there's a certain
madness or philosophy or approach to
raising boys versus girls I hate this
book I don't agree with one word in this
book are you being serious yeah well
maybe there's a few words but this is
these the boys and girls are different
tell me why you know who he is oh
absolutely absolutely I think there's a
lot of everyone's got some choice what
is the one part about the book you
remember that you don't you don't like
yeah well these these a lot of issues
but the whole thing is it's it's almost
like this
it's a control there's a lot of control
that this is what you have to be as
opposed to if it makes fertile okay yeah
no I mean I there's a reason I boys
raised enough girls bring it up boys
there's a bunch of oh okay various
differences between but it I would
always say wet nails because I get asked
this question all the time what I think
is the most important thing is first of
all the I factor which expresses itself
through maleness or femaleness they're
very different there's different
structures sizes in the brain and we
different you subscribe to all five love
languages or no that's it's a way of
understanding I don't think it's as
fixed I think it's so it's a way of
understanding things
32 years you're married to that's your
man right when he starts speaking he
seems like he's got an eagle what I mean
by you go out I mean a negative yes like
he's a man's man he doesn't seem like
he's a you know you got a strong
personality sometimes strong personality
gets him the partner to be a little bit
more timid and a little bit but now he's
very strong he came took a charge here's
what we got here booming rod so what
have you done to better communicate and
deal with your husband for 32 years we
have so much respect for each other he's
my greatest fan on his greatest fan he
is that every event do he's heard me
speak for 32 years he said that is a
huge part of it and also we agree to
disagree and we will have an argument
we'll get it out via voice yes we never
go to bed without me we made a decision
at the beginning when we first started
dating we would never go to bed without
resolving an argument so if we stay up
all night we will never go to bed
without saying I love you I'm sorry and
listening to the other side even if it
took a little screaming to get there do
you put this stuff on his brain when
you're talking to just to kind of see if
or if he's paying attention or not like
what was it do you put that you paying
attention or not what is going on over
here you know my kids say mom don't
psychoanalyze me
yes the part because sometimes you know
when you are when you have a mother like
yourself or a wife it's somebody that
majors in psychology or communication
all that stuff it's always like hey how
do I allow it to happen without no and
analyze over analyzing certain things
that the person is trying to say or if
you know what know many happens is they
all tune Abeka me and say mommy you
think there's a choice you know so there
goes me accountable for it is very cool
yeah that's very good so look I've
really enjoyed this conversation I feel
like you just
by very quickly let's talk about your
book do you want to talk about your
latest book that came out yeah that
thing didn't succeed and that I talk
about them the current situation
technology hearts change of thinking I
talk about 15 mindsets like the
possibilities mindset an expectation and
a mindset is basically how you see the
day your perspective you put up a post
the other day that I use a lot Prince
William the one thing and the three
fingers do you remember putting that up
okay I use that a lot to explain
mindsets
it's your perspective so this book deals
a lot with how you perceive you've
either got a one-finger perspective for
the day or not and these 15 different
perspectives they're kind of set you for
the day and set you for the week and
then I also talked in me about how you
can understand the unique way that you
think feel and choose I developed a
profile for my patients years ago that
our research clinically and of the years
and so on and I've put this very simple
version of it in there there's no wrong
answer there's no measurement it's
simply you understanding how you
uniquely think feel and choose because
we got it realize that you different to
me and we people do that you learn more
effectively your relationships improves
it's a really exciting thing and then
there's a lot about memory the five
steps those five steps how to build your
brain I focus tremendously in this book
on how to build your brain because we've
spoken a lot about detoxing the five
steps i limit i said we limited to 15 to
30 minutes a day so when you're detoxing
you use the five steps because that's
how the five steps are based on how the
science of sort how thought-forms in
your brains but but your mind does it
goes through five steps to grow thought
so you use the same five steps to break
down toxic thoughts and replace them
with healthy you use the same five steps
to build your brain and every human it
should spend at least one to two hours a
day learning new information to the
label where they actually can teach it
exactly so you could spread it across
the day you could and if you think about
much time we waste on facebook and silly
things it's it's deep thinking that deep
intellectual thought otherwise your
brain builds up toxic waste fix your
sleeping we didn't even think I
definitely spent my two hours today you
know spending time with you I learn a
lot spending time with you what we're
gonna do if you're watching is we're
gonna put all the links below to her
book as well as the app again reminders
which link will also be below both of
them the book in the app will be below
and we'll put all of our social media
links as well if you want to follow her
whatever once she tells us the main ones
but
with them below make sure you go
followers well doc preciate you for
coming on this was a blast I really
enjoyed it I did - it was amazing thank
you so much absolutely appreciate it
thank you eating you and thank you for
do you do thank you hope you enjoyed the
interview with the doc doc Caroline leaf
we talked about a lot of different
things if you got any thoughts I want to
hear from you send me a tweet again at
Patrick bate David I got two other
videos I want you to watch if you
enjoyed this interview one of them
especially since we mentioned Jordan
Peterson is my sit-down with Jordan
Peterson in Las Vegas in front of 7,000
people when we interview them there are
some things he says that contradicts a
little bit of what she said so you may
enjoy his interview and the other one is
sitting down with a Robert Green a very
good friend of mine the author of 40 a
loss of power but this one was an
interview we did after he finished his
book laws of human nature he takes a
complete different angle on human nature
is both so if you want to watch this or
this click on them either way enjoy both
interviews take care
[Music]